hi minnie how are you i'm well thanks
how's it going
it's going great i'm even better with
season two of modern love
in my life i am so excited that you are
a part of this season
tell me were you a fan of the first
season of this show and what touched you
about the series that made you want to
be a part of the second
i think it's a brilliant uh show i love
the anthology concept i love that
they're closed-ended
movies really um i wish
lots of i wish they were longer um i
wanted to know
more i wish that they were hour long and
not half hour long but it's
they're beautiful bite-sized stories and
i love
the fact that they're true yeah they are
beautiful
and i'm with you on that i like the
episode that you are in
really touched me i wasn't expecting to
be so touched by it
you know your characters dealing with uh
the loss of her husband and grappling
with the idea of
selling a car that has so many memories
attached to it
is there something in your life that you
could just possibly
not part with is there an item or
something that
just really holds such a special place
in your own heart yeah
definitely my my my mama died recently
and i have
some things of hers that are so
precious um but they are incredibly
life-affirming they remind me of the
life that she
lived they comfort me now that she's
gone and
they're incredibly important totems
for me so i'm very grateful to have that
and i
you just don't realize the significance
that objects will take on
until after someone's past absolutely
you know a lot of people
think of love and think of like rainbows
picket fences butterflies but really
love is much more complicated than that
and especially in like the last year
that we have all had or year plus
how are you keeping modern love alive in
your own life how are you staying
connected because your life
is constantly busy you're traveling
you're working so how do you make sure
that
you are keeping love alive in your own
life well you know
one of the things that came out of this
last year and a half of lockdown
with my family was was
really realizing how when everything is
reduced when all the bells and whistles
are taken away and all of the activities
and the things that we do
to be together the dinners the family
events
the going to a theme park or the beach
when it's just
you and the people that you love you
really get to examine and interrogate
what that means
and as a byproduct in our family it was
a reconnection with those things
yes we fought yes there were problems
but to really know that you love
someone and to feel that in your bones
that was
the greatest gift and
that is the most modern idea it wasn't
it wasn't attached to circumstance or
distractions and events it was just love
for the sake of love
absolutely uh you are part of another
project that i am so excited for
amazon's cinderella i am such a huge fan
of camila this cast though is like
incredible there are so many incredible
people
but tell me were you completely blown
away uh
of her in this role as cinderella
because she just has so much talent
and so much grace like i'm really
excited for this one
oh i can tell you're a big fan we should
be because she's amazing she is an
amazing
wonderful just such a self-possessed
kind woman she's very very talented
she's a very good actress and um i can't
wait for people to see
her in this movie and everybody else i
mean adina menzel
and billy porter james corden
pierce brosnan it's just it's a
wonderful collection
of people and camilla is the best leader
uh and finally very quickly i have been
listening to many questions
with minnie driver you've had so many
incredible people so far
on this podcast uh is there a dream
guest that you would absolutely
love to speak to because you got to put
it out into the universe so who is the
dream for you to have on there
i would really love to interview the
queen
i really would i really would love to
ask
her these questions and i feel like
because it's a very contained podcast
and the questions are very
specific that she would have a lot of
control over it
but you know it's really the queen or
michelle obama and for me they are both
queens
they are both queens you are a queen as
well mini driver thank you so much and
congratulations on season two of modern
love
thank you